Only three days to the World Cotillion!
How does it feel to be the most envied girl in Oregon?
Everybody wants me to be this Lady of the court and I have no idea how to keep up the act
Don't you ever miss screaming at people and just making them run away from you?!
Not really.
This isn't the Isle of the lost Mal!
Believe me, I know that!
I don't belong here!
I'm back
Little Traitor who Grabbed Everything she Wanted and Left me Nothing
but I give my chance to reign them that [yuval] on Oregon [Highway] [out]?
Take it
This is my fault Let's go There and Apologize
Just Wait until em I guess you're Back
Where's Ben [do] not Capture him, do you want beastie Boy back Bringing Fairy Godmothers Magic Boy you
Better Hope your, Girlfriend Comes Through you, always, were Quite the Drama Queen
This Is between you and me You've Been Through a lot together
[Not] Stopping that now You Can stick a cr, on a villa but Still Ability
Losing not an Option Because, we're Rotten to the Core
Take Care by the way I know I'm like Loving it, was like A lot, later, hello
Welcome to Sajha Santosh?
Hi This is Mitch we'll hear It it's Amazing castle, we're About to Shoot Ways to be wicked
And working on Tables or Throwing Papers Everywhere?
We've got all the way to [a] [pa] I'm Caving?
Age [are] Music you See Zombified ordered on Kids which, was so much fun for me
We nailed the biggest Shot Thank you?
Coming to meet you
you